oh my god you hit my friend you friggin
psycho I'm so sorry I feel like I had
stopped no he wasn't you were still
coming back like an idiot oh oh
he just came out of nowhere yeah till
there's your cellmate and my head oh
come on why are you talking like that
come closer I think these might be his
last words maybe on a scale of one to
ten how happy were you in the service
then don't know what I think he said on
a scale of one to ten how happy are you
with your service over a donor I've got
any service I work there work there god
damn it what kind of scam is this I
always liked having blood capsules on
you keep on swallowing them don't waste
people's time sir you should be ashamed
of yourself don't just eat the blood
caps they just swallow you yeah I use
these all the time